we have uh back here on the rich eisen
show one of our favorite guests uh head
coach of the indianapolis colts back
here on the program frank greg how are
you coach
rich how you doing i'll be with you good
to be with you as well i hope you don't
mind uh in solidarity with you uh i i
just want to let you know in advance
this interview will last anywhere
between five to twelve minutes long
you'd be fine with that coach yes sir
i'm totally fine no no i want the 12.
just i want you to know i want the 12 i
know you want the five so i underst i
understand that
i understand in advance i just wanted to
just walk through the door uh so how how
are how was your quarterback and
outstanding stellar uh potential first
uh ballot hall of fame uh
offensive guard how are those guys right
now coach
yeah i appreciate you asking rich
they're doing well i mean everything
from
the day of the surgery until now you
know a little over two weeks later has
gone exactly the way we wanted it to go
so it's it's all been best case scenario
they're making good progress we're not
at the point where we have not
challenged them so to speak
too hard in the rehab process
um so
you know those days are shortly ahead
okay so um obviously you can't you don't
have the proverbial crystal ball which
is one of my favorite coaching cliches
so i appreciate you not going in that
direction but um whence when you talk
with him
how are how are his spirits man i mean
because this guy as you know
has uh been there and done that with
having an injury happen and prevent him
from taking an opportunity that he's
been
preparing for all the time
what what's your conversation with him
been like coach throughout all this yeah
his mind his mindset is what you think
it would be like
he's
you know he is on a mission
he is a man on a mission you know to you
know to get back and get healthy and to
help you know our team win games i i
think he's really
embraced this change this transition in
his life
i think it has suited him well
i think this team this city
uh it's just a good fit and i think as
i've mentioned before maybe we've even
talked about it's all okay i mean he had
a great time and a really good run and
some special things in philly
and uh you know now it's time for the
change and so we're really excited to
have him i think he's doing exceedingly
well i think his mindset is he's going
to be back sooner rather than later but
unfortunately we don't know that until
we actually get out on the field and
start to get to the point where we can
test it and see how it's going to
respond when do you think that can
happen do you think that can happen
before week one
coach i think we're gonna yeah oh yeah i
do think what will happen i do think the
testing of it is gonna be an ongoing
process like
like anyone would expect we'll go out
there and um
in any rehab process you you challenge
yourself a little bit more every day so
part of that will start to be field work
you know we just things have been more
in the training room and that kind of
thing and now slowly field work will
stomach will come into play um doing a
few things on the field moving around on
the field throwing on the field i'm at
some level and as you know um there's a
lot of you know we could stand here and
play catch 10 yards apart you know on a
with a cast on your foot so that doesn't
tell you anything it just tells you that
it's we have to push it and see how it
responds as we go
and uh in terms of you know the the
backup plan you know because again
i i i made reference to it in the five
to 12 weeks that
you know we heard that would be a time
frame as to when
whence might return or how long he might
be out the the un you know tested or
inexperienced nature of the backups that
you have there what has been the backup
plan for you just trying to get the kids
and youngsters grown up fast or looking
outside the organization in any way that
you can share with me
yeah right now all of our focus all of
our focus and efforts have been internal
and you know we're pleased with the
progress
one of the reasons like we feel like we
can do that is you know we felt good
about both these guys when we drafted
them um you know we feel like we have a
good team surrounding them so you know
we don't need someone to come in and be
a superstar sure you always want the
best player available but you know you
know we're on a you know there's there's
a way we're doing things here in a way
we're trying to build and grow this team
and um you know we feel like the two
guys we have in-house right now are
making good progress and proving
themselves you know worthy of that you
know to be in that you know to be that
as the top two considerations right i
mean so there's been no external
conversations at this point you haven't
spoken to a certain high school coach
down in alabama that was your starter
last year
coach have you spoken
yeah i have actually spoke i actually
have spoken to him one time um who who
is one of my all-time favorites
um
he's a special guy so but i keep in
touch with him all the time regardless
frank reich here on the rich eisen show
what about big q where does he stand
for you quentin nelson same place carson
does he's doing great he's doing great
obviously they play two different
positions so
what they do to test what they do to
field test it will look a little bit
different but the process will be the
same
and in terms of you know uh head coaches
in the nfl obviously
you know everybody who's i've met uh
wants to control everything control
freak is definitely the words that i use
who was the one who explained to you
that it's a 5 to 12 week time frame
and and walk you through that process
coach
yeah
i appreciate that being stated like that
i mean no i mean basically
obviously as a team you know we we
naturally don't want to over promise and
under deliver we naturally want to be
vague
you know we want to be vague in our
answers everybody knows that but those
are the that's the range that the
two top guys in the country who have
done thousands of these surgeries
um
have had eyes fall in in that range so
it is what it is right um
and there's a need for us right to go
into all the particulars of what makes a
12-week case or what makes a five-week
case um
i'll continue to say i've said around
here i don't mind saying i think and i
hope we're much closer to the front end
and the better end of this range and um
with how the surgery went and talking to
the doc after the surgery and what he
saw in the surgery
very encouraged very encouraged by
talking to our trainers very encouraged
and talking to carson and quentin so
you know we'll just continue to go down
that road frank wright indianapolis head
coach here on the rich eisen show what
else makes you very encouraged who else
has been flashing we're not talking
about because we're so focused on the
five to 12 weeks for your quarterback
and your stellar offensive lineman yeah
who are we not talking about i'll give
you the floor on that
you know
you can you can talk about a lot of guys
really you know on offense uh you know a
lot of the buzz around here as i'm sure
you've heard his is our rookie receiver
mike strong you know big man who is who
can uh who can elevate who has really
good hands running very good routes the
game's not too big for him he's looked
really good but our whole receiving core
right in this last in our first game or
our young receiving court they really
all showed themselves made a bunch of
plays down the field
and and obviously both jacob eason and
sam allenger you know had had good games
and
as a whole i thought our defense played
very well
in the first preseason game a lot a lot
of good things a lot of those young
players
stepped up and played good football
how's my michigan man quitty pay
i've been trying to hold off on just
going straight back up straight for the
movie
he's back
yeah he's back on the field you know
unfortunately you know he sprained that
ankle you know about a few days before
this first game
but he's back on the practice field now
happy to be there and
um you know before he sprained his ankle
he was looking phenomenal
we feel really good about his
development his progress as a young
player um feel like he's going to
make a an early impact for us well you
know and then just somebody who's in
terms of impactful and um a great
story for those of us in in the media to
talk about you know guys who who are not
very well known when they're drafted in
the league and then they make the most
of their opportunity and then get paid
is darius leonard uh what can you give
me a story about when you first were
either
um uh you know introduced exposed to his
uh heart and style and what he
brings
to all of that on your behalf and the
organization's behalf in between the
lines in the locker room i just would
love a good darius leonard story from
you
yeah uh
so i probably don't have one story but
to me
it's a very easy answer okay and that is
it's the cute it's the cumulative effect
of how he is all the time like when you
see him when he's mic'd up
like that's how he is all the time
i mean he it it's never off this guy is
always on he has got so much juice
and he brings so much energy to the
practice field to the meeting room
walking down the hall he's a he's just
he's just a great leader you know he he
has a way of elevating whatever space
he's occupying if you're within striking
distance you're going to feel his energy
and
what's not to like about that why who
wouldn't love this guy and then oh yeah
by the way he's one of the best
defensive players in the nfl he makes
play he can do everything he can rush
the passer he gets he turns the ball
over he can get interceptions and then
he's going to have a hundred and some
tackles every year i mean
i mean what a great draft pick by chris
ballard um
i can't say enough about darius so happy
that we were able to get his contract
done and get him extended and uh you
know that was a big deal for us and for
this city does he remind you of anybody
you played with or against
in your day
oh man i'm terrible with these questions
oh
um sorry i'll give it to you buddy
i'd love to know i'm just curious
probably a combination of but but maybe
nobody
i can i can safely say i've played with
and coached
a lot of guys who have a lot of juice
and have a lot of energy and
i can say that darius has more than
anybody i know no kidding hands down
it's not it's just hands down yeah no i
remember having a conversation you were
talking about philip rivers earlier
and uh we were we were having a
conversation this offseason and just
kind of reminiscing about last year and
and that was that was one of philip
rivers talking points like man i'm never
going to forget that year what an
amazing what a great team what great
locker room and him just talking about
darius and the first time he met darius
and then just
how he was
um
as i just was talking about just always
like that like just he was waiting he
was waiting to see
him tone it down and that's just that
moment never came he doesn't even know
how he talked well i mean neither does
phillip sometimes you know
that's why that's why he appreciated it
you know they they have a connection on
having an inability to sometimes tone it
down um and speaking of toning it down
before i let you go um
so much being talked about that play in
your preseason game with benny lemay
getting a flag
for staring down
for just a split second
uh one of the many people who are unable
to tackle him
and um
and and and this is this is a concern
for fans and a lot of a lot of players
are
a little pissed off to be honest with
you because
you know here's a kid who who's trying
to make your team right he's trying to
also prove prove a point and
he might have lost it for a split
nanosecond but out comes the flag
because there's a new emphasis on
on what uh uh the
co-owner of the giants john marrow who's
been in the league a long time and is
part of the competition because he's
sick of all the of the talking
and i wonder what you think of this and
what you might have spoken to your team
about after that
coach frank wright yeah i mean
you're right it wasn't nanosecond but
here's the thing i mean i really don't
think it's that big of a deal i actually
think
i'm kind of glad people are talking
about it you know i like when people
talk about our team okay but it's the
pre-season it's a point of emphasis so
we know every year those of us
including the fans who we all watch
football we all love football in
whatever form preseason regular season
post season and when the officials have
a point of emphasis
and you even sniff that line in a
pre-season game especially the first
preseason game they're gonna throw the
flag and because it's a point of
emphasis and it doesn't really it's not
a regular season and they want to put
the league on notice put coaches and
players on notice that hey guys we told
you we're going to emphasize this
hey maybe this was kind of questionable
maybe it wasn't but we just want to make
a point here
i kind of get that i do i agree with the
call it doesn't even matter whether i
agree with the call or not but i kind of
get what they do i've just seen it done
for many years
especially in the first preseason game
it's gonna happen no exactly right i i
was talking about that the other day but
do you then make it a point of emphasis
to say exactly what you said to your
team to say hey that's what that was in
preseason week one let's make sure
you know week one when it all matters in
the win loss record for now an 18 week
17 game regular season game that we
don't do that right or no
no i do and without like you said so
here's what here's what i'll tell you
this is one of those things i can tell
you exactly what i said to the team
please hey guys we know there's a point
a point of emphasis
hey how we do things here um
we we don't want to talk we don't need
to taunt we not we're not that kind you
know that's not how we do things uh the
way we do things is all this juice and
energy have we're directing towards our
teammates and to the success that we're
having and you know we don't need to
talk now that was i wasn't saying that
against benny because i didn't i thought
he was i thought it was fine but in
general hey let this is a point of
emphasis let's not let this we don't
want a 15-yard penalty we all know that
let's
let's celebrate
like i want to appropriately celebrate
each other and each other's success as a
team
but
the talk around the league and i agree
with this i really don't think there's
room for taunting i don't want taunting
i don't like taunting i mean i love i
love the fire of competition i wanna i
want to dominate the opponent i mean i
want to dominate the opponent in every
way physically mentally on the
scoreboard i want to embarrass them i i
want you know we want to destroy the
opponent we we want to shut every
opponent out we want to score 50 and and
have them not score any
but we don't have to taunt i just that's
a bad that's a bet taunting is uh as
some people would say
it's not it's it doesn't look good on
anybody i i just it's not a good look
it's not a good thing for young kids to
see i just don't think that's what this
game is about
coach i got to be honest with you after
hearing that um you make me want to go
hit somebody i'll be cool i mean i i
like let's go i mean i'm all
i'm all i'm all fired up like this is
this is great and you're ready for week
one right now i bet right like and uh
you know i just um i'm i'm excited for
you and your team you know i'm a big fan
of jonathan taylor's too um so good luck
and
right
you don't have to you don't have to have
that conversation with him i bet you
know i mean he's ready to go yeah that
guy i i love it i say his name and you
go oh man
that's terrific that's how you feel
about him too huh yeah oh my gosh that
is yeah he's just he's a special player
special person thanks for the time
appreciate it good luck look forward to
seeing your team out there in uh in week
number one and beyond and let's uh let's
let's just keep connecting always enjoy
our chats thank you
thanks rich you got it that's frank
reich head coach of the indianapolis
colts
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here